so you you have kind of done kind of
fights and we've actually already
children we have yes basic you have
noticed that my dogs fights in a
particular way no he makes certain
noises when he face
oh yes again because he works out all
the time on set and he makes a lot of
noise when I boxed as Michael never
boxes my got better been sort of our own
Michael well he's on the pads and then
we take it in turns in the pads and you
did you send that Ricky Hatton and that
you sound like you're having off or
something my mother was always Monica
Seles
[Laughter]
it helps me breathe to be honest yeah
that's that's why I do it to make the
noise yeah but does he make the noise
all the time Marian yeah and sometimes
you don't really know what he's doing
you say what are you doing in there
working on you guys have talked about
the x-men set the games you play and
like the last ten but in this last x-men
movie you did a new game which just none
of these games sounds fun to me but you
know I see like them
well it's you kind of get sort of drawn
into them it's not that they're sort of
that enjoyable they're quite de
nerve-racking at times like the stopping
game just sounds like you're just
slapping people the game is that you do
a shot don't you yeah and right after
you take the shot you get slapped in the
face yeah do you buy the purse in the
shop they drink it and then you slap
them talking everyone's yeah no no it's
just you just deport each and you both
have one you both get hurt yeah lead to
employment for me which is good how did
this happen we would all maybe that part
of you're in San Diego at comic-con
didn't you knock someone out there
[Laughter]
particular I've never felt less male a
particular
open-handed strike that you're talking
about um the the director of the film
that I want to talk about tonight split
M night Shyamalan saw that going don't
and Andy was like hey that's the bald
guy that I should get for my film and so
he invited me over and was like hey Mike
just I would you want to come and have a
chat sometime I was like okay cool see
ya and then we wouldn't be made a movie
with each other because it kinda comes
of that woman
[Music]